all right the united nations general
assembly kicks off a two-day virtual
meeting on the coronavirus pandemic
today
while it comes as the virus continues to
spread across the globe more than 60
million cases
have been recorded so far with more than
1.5
million deaths from covet 19. north and
south america as well as europe have
seen a
massive resurgence in recent weeks in
asia
india has fought is has fared far
worse than its neighbors the u.n
conference is meant to address the
negative effects of the pandemic on
jobs economics and global trade and
travel
i'd like to turn now to professor
calypso chalkidoo
she is the director of the global health
policy at
center for global development a very
warm welcome
professor good to have you here with us
now it's a very delicate balancing act
for policymakers around the world i mean
how should they balance economic losses
a covet fatigue that is setting in among
the general public
and the still rising number of
infections
as you say it's a very difficult balance
i don't think there's a straightforward
answer but i think what
is important is to continue to persevere
with collecting information
uh being able to synthesize this
information including
the trade-offs as you say between
economic damage
and welfare damage more generally in
people's livelihoods
caused either directly by the virus or
indeed by the
response to the virus and then be able
to communicate this to the population
to ensure that the trust levels are
strong and building as opposed to waning
and so that people are on board the
measures that governments take
now help is on the way in the form of
upcoming vaccination programs possible
treatments and rapid testing
um do you do you feel that these
solutions will be
um uh spread out distributed in an
equitable way
well i think that as you say these are
encouraging news especially on the
vaccines
i think we still need to look at the
data we need to
rely on more than press releases we need
to
look at peer-reviewed publications of
the results but in the meantime our
regulators here in europe in the united
kingdom
in the united states are proceeding with
emergency authorization processes
and that's important and understandable
in terms of equitable access i think
it's uh reasonable to assume that
wealthier nations
those with those advanced deals with
companies
will be the first to get the vaccine and
distribute to their populations
followed by resource-constrained
countries
professor how long away is there still
ahead of us i mean people are so
encouraged by this news of
vaccines now being approved but
realistically are we looking at
still a year that we have to deal with
this
well there's a lot a lot is uncertain so
i i i mean i have to speculate but i
think in my mind at least
as far as the northern hemisphere is
concerned of the western hemisphere the
europe uh north america i think
you know i'm hoping for a normal
christmas uh this time next year
i think it will take several months for
the vaccine to be
shipped after uh the authorization
processes are completed
and then to be distributed uh in a
tiered way as you've been describing
high-risk groups first and then
uh on forth to other population groups
and then to establish
that uh it is working as as you said
um two doses may well be required so
we might be looking most certainly be
looking at uh to
those vaccination schedules so that will
take time to and then make you need to
make sure that obviously it's safe
it works how well it works in which
populations
so in parallel to this process we'll
have to sustain the social distancing
measures the non-pharmacological
interventions so-called
npis to make sure that we don't see
resurgent peaks so that will take time
it will take certainly several months
professor calypso chalky do a director
of global health policy at center for
global development thank you for joining
us
thank you let's take a look now at the
latest developments in the coronavirus
pandemic the number of people
hospitalized with covid19 in the united
states
has reached 100 000 an all-time high
as the pandemic increases the strain on
health care systems there
meanwhile greece has extended its
nationwide log down for another week
after a slower than expected decline
in case numbers and in italy that
country will place
strict limits on travel over the
christmas and new year's
holidays a movement between the regions
will be banned from december 21st
russian president vladimir putin has
ordered voluntary mass
vaccinations to start next week moscow
says
its sputnik vaccine is 90
95 rather percent effective
and we stay with russia that country's
second wave of coronavirus has hit
some of its re regions specifically hard
in
many cities there are hardly any
hospital beds left
official statistics say almost 40 000
people in russia have died from
coronavirus
but media reports say the excess
mortality in the country is
four times higher than last year our
correspondent
emily sherwin went to the city of ufa in
the country's
southwest where it's mainly undertakers
who experience these grim figures first
hand
with a steady stream of coronavirus dead
speed is of the essence at the morgue
every morning the team from the funeral
agency ufaritoual comes here to collect
new victims of the pandemic 29 year old
artur kinzikev has been working at the
funeral home for 12 years
but he says he's never had to bury this
many bodies
one time there was a huge line of
hearses standing in line outside the
morgue
it was only then that people started to
understand the death had really come
call the relatives to identify the body
this morgue in the city of ufa is only
for those who died of the coronavirus or
had contact with an infected person
the bodies have to be sealed in plastic
the coffins closed
many russians feel their dead should be
treated with more respect
artor explains
their relatives are often more tense
than usual because they're dead or
handed over to them in plastic body bags
some people cry and demand that we open
the bags
then i have to explain that they could
get infected themselves
this virus is no joke
has been in the business for seven years
today he's in charge of the team of
undertakers
he says since the second wave of
coronavirus there have been at least
twice as many deaths in the city of ufa
funeral agencies have had a tough time
keeping up
we have more work a lot more work over a
million people live in ufa
the capital of the republic of
bashkortostan government statistics say
that
only around 80 people in the region have
died of the coronavirus since the
pandemic began
but official numbers also show that
during that time
over 4 000 more people died than in the
same period last year
coronavirus infections are spiking
across russia
but authorities insist the situation is
under control
the undertakers aren't so sure today
yuri kazlof and his team are entering a
92 year old woman
she didn't die of the coronavirus that
means her relatives can say their final
farewell with an open casket
which is the tradition in russia
usually funerals are big family affairs
in russia
but the pandemic has changed that people
are often worried about getting infected
and stay away
so far no one on yuri's team has caught
kovit
he can only hope it will stay that way
in russia people say if it's decided up
there that you'll get run over by a
streetcar
you won't drown fate is fate
the next day the team prepares for four
more funerals
artur and his colleagues hardly have
time to worry about their own health
at the moment they're just too busy
of course emily sherwin reporting there
she joins us now from
moscow truly heartbreaking stuff there
emily what's driving the increase in
cases and deaths in
russia's regions
well during the second wave of the
coronavirus
that has really the disease has really
hit
across russia in the first wave it was
kind of focused on moscow the capital
actually the numbers of overall deaths
across russia
aren't that high comparatively with
other countries like the u.s
here the official number is just 40
thousand
but uh there have been a lot of
questions raised about those numbers
since the beginning of the pandemic and
recently
journalists have been pointing out that
the official numbers of deaths
um across the country uh for the period
of the pandemic this year
are much much higher than the same
period last year
so those extra excess deaths are much
higher than the official coronavirus
statistics so that could mean that
covet deaths are actually much higher
and despite questions over those
death numbers it's clear that the health
system at the moment
is kind of overstretched even according
to official information
the health minister at the beginning of
this month said that around 80 percent
of hospital beds across russia
were occupied at the moment in some re
region the number is as high as
95 and there have been reports of kind
of medicines running out of doctors
being overstretched
and even of seats hospital seats instead
of beds being offered
in one siberian city our attitudes
emily towards the virus changing in
russia
well surveys show that during the first
wave of the pandemic around 30 percent
of people were
concerned about covet now that number
has risen to around 60 percent so it has
doubled but my sense is that people
kind of really start to believe that
covett is a real threat
when someone that they know is actually
affected or when they themselves
are affected and the undertakers that i
spoke to in that report that we just saw
also said that they know a lot of people
who simply don't believe
that coronavirus is real and they don't
necessarily believe the government
um on that um and also fatalism
um this sense uh that if i get sick then
that's my fate
that's very widespread a very kind of
russian
attitude meanwhile emily russia has
announced it will be rolling out a
vaccination a program how will that work
well yesterday uh russian president
vladimir putin said around
2 million doses of sputnik v one of the
two
russian vaccines is actually ready to go
and he
ordered the government to start rolling
out the vaccination program
next week the mayor of
moscow the capital seemingly trying to
get ahead of everyone else
has today announced that uh people will
be able to sign up
to get vaccinated starting from tomorrow
and that
vaccination centers across the city 70
of them
will be open from morning till night on
saturday so people can start getting
vaccinated here in the capital
from this coming saturday it's clear
that that quick rollout is a bit of a
political thing
russia since the beginning of this
pandemic has wanted to be at the
forefront
of the race uh for the vaccine we've
seen that in the numbers
um that they've been reporting on
effectiveness when a western vaccine
comes out and said
we have 90 percent effectiveness russia
kind of
one-ups them every time all right emily
sherwin reporting from moscow thank you
the head of germany's public health
institute says he expects the
coronavirus pandemic
to claim many more lives at a news
conference the president of the robert
koch institute
lotar wheeler said germany has managed
to
stabilize the rate of new infections
through restrictions in the past weeks
but he's stressed the case load remains
too high while mr wheeler said he was
particularly concerned about the rate of
infections
in care homes where increasing numbers
of elderly residents are contracting the
virus
and he warned that hospitals are coming
under
growing strain within this
in some regions we're seeing hospitals
reach the limits of their capacities
and as a result are having to postpone
surgeries or treatments
we also see the number of severe cases
and deaths rising from week to week
and since both always occur after a
certain time lag
we must expect many more
all right uh let's take you uh now to
dw's political correspondent
emmanuel who is following this story
very
closely uh for you emma what's behind
the rise of these uh
of these death rates uh here in germany
well lila you have to look at where the
infections happen of course
more infections mean more deaths but not
only this time around the virus has
spread much more widely and in places
like hospitals and care homes
where it affects vulnerable people
there's infections also
among the younger population and among
people over 80 in care homes the death
rate for people infected by kovin 19 is
20 that is one-fifth of the people
infected while the first time around
in a spring with a virus more localized
it was
much easier to contain and according to
lota
velar much more needs to be done to
protect those vulnerable people he said
otherwise
we can expect many more deaths from a
virus that
he said ultimately is up to each and
every one of us to control by avoiding
con
contacts with others as much as possible
and i'm going to push on hold for just a
second we're going to continue our
conversation
after this because german chance angela
merkel has confirmed
that a partial lockdown will remain in
place until
at least early january but restrictions
on get-togethers will be
loosened for christmas even though some
public health experts warn of the
consequences
winter is coming and german chancellor
angela merkel warned
it could be a long one
we had already made clear in november
that unless there were significant
changes for the better
it was highly likely that the measures
in place until december 20 would be
extended
and that's what we've now agreed to do
with the record daily death toll
reported on wednesday
the partial lockdown has done little to
turn the tide here in germany
[Music]
the question is whether we leave the
country in this state of half sleep
or if we decide at some point to
introduce significantly tougher measures
we'll see how efficient the measures
currently in place
are for now the restrictions will remain
in place until january 10th
for the vendors here at berlin's famous
christmas market this is not
the season to be jolly as visitors will
only be allowed to buy their malt wine
and sizzling sausages to go
we need to ask ourselves what to do we
don't know what will happen
it's not really a christmas market just
a few stands
i was there last year before i flew back
to italy it was wonderful
i think it's a real shame that there's
nothing this year i'm really sorry
restaurants and bars had to close when
the partial lockdown was introduced in
november
many are now looking to take out orders
and loyal customers
to stay afloat
a a bit difficult at the moment of
course but we're doing our best
we're open for takeouts with new offers
and our regular customers support us
we'll see how long it lasts i really
hope this situation ends soon
for many the promise of a vaccine has
offered a glimmer of hope
but until then many worry it's going to
be a long
and lonely christmas let's talk now
about christmas with emmanuel emma um
so restrictions are going to be loose
are supposed to be loosened over the
christmas holiday is that a wise
decision well it's something that angela
merkel wants she couldn't guarantee
this is the plan right now but also for
example if you take the case of the
german capital of berlin its mayor
mikhail muller already said that there
will be no loosening of restrictions in
berlin because the seven days
incidence the infection rate is still
way too high in the german capital it is
170 per hundred thousand
inhabitants over a period of seven days
which is
way higher than the goal of this
lockdown which is to bring
this number back to below 50. so
those there is a losing plan but at the
same time
the situation right now doesn't indicate
that it is in
any case the wise move to make and and
they're not committing to it to judging
by your what you're reporting let's talk
about the partial log down that is in
place in germany
uh right now it was meant to bend the
curve
it is not doing that where is it going
wrong
well because it's partial so it takes
time for num for the number of
infections to significantly drop right
now the light lock down as it's called
here
has stopped the exponential growth of
infections but it hasn't significantly
reduced the number of infections today
we saw a little bit above
22 000 new cases on day one of the
current lockdown on november 2
this was 23 and 300 cases so we stagnate
with significantly more deaths this
partial lockdown now is
set to be extended until january 10th at
least
some areas which are particularly
infected with high infection rates like
nurnberg in bavaria some districts in
saxony have introduced even
tougher measures with people ordered to
not leave their home without good reason
and marcus the state premiers of bavaria
spoke of toughening measures nationwide
we heard it in the report either we
leave this country in that state of
half-sleep or we take action to tackle
the virus
all right reporting from berlin thank
you
well the uk on wednesday became the
first country in the world to
authorize a vaccine developed by beyond
tech pfizer
while the u.s and the eu are expected to
follow suit in the coming weeks but
doses
of the vaccine will initially be in
short supply
raising the question of who should be
top of the list to receive
it everyone in the world who wants to
get vaccinated against covet 19 should
be able to
at least that's the idea but demand for
the vaccine is likely to be much greater
than the initial supply
now governments must decide who comes
first and who must wait
most agree that fair distribution should
take place independent of a country
or individual's ability to pay in
britain
an independent commission has developed
a multi-step plan
according to the key factors of
infection risk and age
residents and employees in nursing homes
take first priority
next in line are those over 80 years old
and then health care professionals
then high risk adults under 65 can take
their turn
followed by seniors over 65.
and the most important thing is to make
sure that we get people um
as many people as possible starting with
the the most vulnerable and then those
who work in the frontline of the nhs
vaccinated effectively
in countries with federal states like
germany or the u.s the decision will be
left to individual states
the u.s advisory commission recommends
that residents of nursing homes and
health care workers
be vaccinated first germany is also
working to create a system of
prioritizing vaccinations
chancellor angela merkel says above all
it won't be mandated
nobody will be forced to be vaccinated
this is a voluntary decision
the question of who will be vaccinated
first is being discussed
with the vaccination commission with the
leopoldina academy of science
and with the ethics commission
but i think i can already reveal this
much first and foremost of course
we have nurses doctors and people in
high risk groups
only after 60 to 70 of people have
become immune to the virus
will the pandemic be considered defeated
and reaching that point worldwide will
still take time